hello everyone and welcome to the game
you've all been waiting for and to the
opening you've all been waiting for it's
alpha zero versus stockfish and the
opening is well you all know what the
opening is and it's from the match where
you know they play the first part of the
match was where they just play whatever
they wanted and the second part was
where where they play that predefined
openings first alpha alpha play
something with white pieces then so
first places were the white pieces and
often in storage and then until they
deplete all of the openings which is a
very interesting to see which openings
you know the humans had correct and you
know which new ideas can come out of
some some of the openings so without
further ado let's check it out alpha
zero with the white pieces opens with E
4 and I didn't have to say this game
comes as a suggestion from a subscriber
Dario this is the second game Dario
already suggested and it's quite a
lovely one not gonna talk too much about
list let's just see what happens with
'if I've by stockfish Knight f3 Knight
to c6 and Bishop to c4 with Bishop to c5
and now for the first time in a very
long time we have before the Evans
gambit is on the board Bishop captures
zombie force polish accepts the gambit
we have c3 Bishop to a5 and now d4 so
here you could go into ECAP force on d4
where you get Queen to b3 and then a lot
of complicated things happen but here is
it's still pretty defined with these
sets by stockfish Queen to b3
threatening on f7 and now Queen to d7
defending and Knight B to d2 and it is
of this moment that the moves are no
longer predefined now stockfish is on
the move and we have Bishop to b6 of
course well-known idea in the Evans
gambit you want to play nice day a5
attack of the Queen and the bishop get
rid of White's LightSquared Bishop
stockfish alpha doesn't mind alpha just
castles here and mountain Knight to a5
with Queen to c2 and here there are a
few moves known in this position I'd
captures and c4 is unknown move Knight
to e7 is a non move even f6 is a non
move but here it's actually stockfish
who plays a new move ECAP for somebody
for is a new move in this position and
it is already as a move ten in the Evans
gambit that we
a completely new game so let's see what
happens
see capture sandy for now alpha creates
a very strong Center which is always a
trade-off in the Evans gambit you give
up some material but you have a very
nice Center and very nice development
with Knights the e7 stock fish prepares
the castle rook to e1 and now just
castles buy stock fish and now stock
fish could have captured this Bishop on
every move but stalkerish preferred
development and only now does alpha
retreat to f1 Bishop the f1 attacking
the bishop in for later as now that the
black can has castle now alpha would
very much like to save the bishop pair
queen back to d8 by stock fish preparing
to develop delight square bishop and now
Bishop to a3 another standard developing
move in the Evans gambit with Knight to
g6 by stock fish and now d5 humans are
more often than not reluctant to play
such a move as once you push a pond you
can never undo it but alpha really loves
grabbing more space so d5 is a basically
a signature alpha move we've looked at
EMI stock fish and now comes Bishop to
b4 Bishop to b4 is a very strange move I
thought about it a lot and then it took
me a while to realize why it Bishop to
b4 was played because if you want to
bring the bishop over to this diagonal
for example for b2 to g7 then why not
just play Bishop to b2 but the thing is
after Bishop to b4 stock first idea was
rook to b8 and now after rook a to D 1
by alpha we have c6 and now Queen to be
2 so this is the the the setup that
alpha wants now alpha 1 stock fish here
sorry Bishop here our Queen B - Bishop 2
C 3 battery and the bishop will be
eyeing the g7 pawn the now the idea is
that if stock will decides to open up
the center with pawn captures here and
it captures on d5 the ropes can be
traded alpha will be very strong here as
the route will be very silly here
officer still controlling controlling
much more space so the idea is for
example why Bishop to b4 instead of
Bishop to b2 is Bishop to b2 and then we
go into the same idea Ruby
rook 81 by alpha and c6 now the
difference is that after alpha makes
some sort of move let's say h3c chapters
and e5 will not will be actually good
for stockfish after he captures and this
trade happens at rook captures rook
captures now it's it's a bit it's a bit
different Bishop to d7 and now starfish
has rook the c8 so the queen is now here
instead of here so perhaps this roped
the c8 which is well coming next is win
of a temple for sawfish so this is
probably why i also prefer the that line
to this line so returning to that Bishop
to b4 instead of Bishop to b2 really no
idea who would play this rook to b8 like
we said rook a b1 c6 now threatening C
captors here but now Queen to be to
preparing this and now stockfish doesn't
like the idea we already shown it yeah
now comes c5 now stop which grabs more
space and now Bishop to c3 so still
saving the disappear now attacking the
g7 pawn and we have f6 just defending it
and here if you give this position to an
engine to a traditional engines one such
a stock fish stock which will say black
is better but alpha is no ordinary
opponent menorah an ordinary engine and
alpha disagrees with a for alpha grabs
more space on the Queen side
Bishop to c7 now maybe preparing a six
and B 5 and now Queen to a to putting
the Queen on this nice diagonal that the
King occupies we have Brooke to e7 and
now comes h3 with Bishop to d7 and now
looked a one probably prematurely
defending the a for pawn is a stock fish
might have some ideas of going Queen to
e8 and then the a four point would be
under attack so King day Jade stop which
now gets the King out of this diagonal
and now Knight to h2 maybe with the
ideas of grabbing even more space with
f4 with the Shabak the b6 by stock fish
and now look 8b one King back to g8 buy
stock fish and now Knight H back to f3
I've obviously decided not the over over
grab space in the center
Bishop - eh Nami
good ideas of bringing the bishop over
here to concert of Queen and King to H
do now with Russia back to c7 sort of
issue you know feeling the terrain
seeing what alpha has in mind and now
looked a bit too often I'll prepares to
double up on the B file with rook to a
eight and now comes Luke to a one again
Bishop back the d7 and now Queen to be
one now putting pressure on the b7 phone
and now just Bishop to c8 so the knight
will be able to move from here at some
point maybe b6 can be played Knight b7
something like that but the bishop and
CH keeps a very solid defensive to b7
pawn and well the problem is that this
rook is still on AAA and now Knight to G
1 now alpha once Knight to e2 followed
by Knight to g3 with Queen to f8
stockfish now prepares f5 to open up the
position and Knight to e2 alpha
continues with the plan with f5 and now
Knight the g3 and now of course as the
e4 pawn is nicely defended stockfish
decides to push f4 with f4 attacking the
knight and now Knight to f5 so you don't
want to leave a knight on e5 it's a it's
a beautiful night and whites lights
where the ship isn't doing all that much
so stuffy decides to give it up with the
shop character son f5 e captures on f5
and now Knight to e5 and I square for
the knight also blocking the bishops
attack towards the g7 pawn now alpha
retreats Knight to f3 well basically not
retreat but attacks Knight f3 going
after the night here and here would you
play here
you could try captures captures but then
the G file will be opened will be used
by white for attacking and also f6 is
such a powerful strong move that will
open up the position and black has
really no good reply to it so not a good
idea to actually trade here even though
it messes up White's pawn structure in
front of the King here we have Queen to
f6 preparing to bring the other look
into the game also putting more defense
to d5 Knight and now Queen to c2 alpha
prepares to bring the other look into
the game will be six now finally making
room for the night to enter the game
also the b7 point is no longer a target
and rook to e1 now alpha brings the rook
into the game with rook the f8 stockfish
also does the same and Queen to d1 now
preparing to bring the other rook over
to the e-file as well we have looked at
d7 by stockfish and now Bishop to b5
pushing the rule back with rudy' to d8
and now rook to c2 the idea is keeping
an eye on the c4 pawn for now on the C 4
square for now as both of the night
might have ideas so for jumping over to
c4 well not this one as it's currently
pinned but in the future so Queen
captures an f5 grabbing back the pawn
also unpinning and here we have rooks
c2e2 finally doubling up on the e-file
you can also control the c-4 square from
Eve 4 so it's not a problem with nice to
b7 and here is where the where the fun
really starts here alpha plays at Bishop
to a6 now what's the idea here well the
knight is under attack and here you have
to play Knight back to a5 which is not
something you want to do that night is
really ugly on a5 the problem is if ruby
8 well then you have a rookin b8 but
it's even worse you actually lose the
game here so feel free to pause the
video and try to see what alpha had in
mind here in this position it's it's a
nice tactical shot I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent beater of stockfish you
know not for real but in an imaginary
line and for those who just want to
enjoy Bishop captures on e5 a beautiful
line pawn captures now Bishop captures
on b7 route captures and b7 and now d6
as the knight no longer keeps an eye on
the d6 square and now you either have to
give up the bishop or you play something
like there should be eight and then
comes not check with 25 because the rook
can block rook f7 but there is Knight
captures on e5 and now it's just Queen
d5 is coming UK you cannot use any of
these squares
sorry it's the drawing of the square the
calling of the squares is a bit harder
on my laptop but all of these squares
are now covered by the pawn and by the
night so with 25 will be deadly so
whatever you're playing
you don't want the Queen d5 to come with
check 25 and now you don't have a good
move Ruby 8 you have to get out of the
way Knight of 7 check is just deadly if
you capture with the rook rook e8 will
be will be terrible after of course
Queen captures and if you capture with
the Queen it's no better just Queen
captures rook captures and now it's just
mate so this is what alpha had in mind
if if Ruby 8 so Knight has to go back
back to a5 and now rook to e4 just
grabbing more space not allowing this
Knight to enter get the game via the c-4
square as now the rook and the bishop
controlled the c-4 square we have Queen
back to f6 by stockfish and now Bishop
back to be 597 and now comes the Bishop
to c4 here alpha has a different plan
for the bishop now the bishop is now
coming over to a2 b1 and from there the
plan is the pressure h7 so this is
really really insane with Knight to a5
again pressuring the Bishop Bishop to a
- and now King to h8 again getting out
of this nasty diagonal and out Bishop
the B 1 by alpha so stockfish really
tied down it's always interesting you
know try playing stock with yourself
you're just gonna get destroyed in 15
maybe - 20 moves but when alpha placed
on fish it's like stock fish is really
you know all tied up with Lube dt8 now
as alpha we'll be putting a lot of
pressure on the e-file and now King back
to G 1 by alpha King to g8 as the bishop
no longer controls this diagonal and now
H for preparing the Knight to g5 and
here if you allow Knight to g5 the night
is coming to East 6 and then the game is
pretty much over
the question is how do you stop 90 g5
there are two ways you can capture the
night with check or you could play h6
now let's discuss those options if
Knight captures with check Queen
captures the Queen is still under attack
the Bishop can capture so let's say
Queen f7
now comes looked at east 6 and you don't
have a lot of good moves here whatever
you play you could try not reacting to
the move you could try Knight b7 but
then you just get Queen here and then
it's either mate
you you loser look there is no way
around it so this is just black is
busted here so you have to capture and
if you capture it's no better D captures
any six threatens the Queen Queen e8 now
again just queen g4 you threaten mate
here
g6 and now e seven this is just this is
just beautiful stuff here so there is
not much you can do here you could try
something like moving the rook but it
doesn't really help you where you're
gonna move the rook the bishop repair
another case of a bishop repair from
hell once this bishop comes to a - it's
all over it's pointless to play this so
this that's one way to do it after h4
but obviously capturing here doesn't
work so how about h6
if h6 preventing 95 then Knight the h2
and now you have a lot of other
weaknesses here on the light squares as
the night is still thin the due to the
Bishop Knight g4 will be just deadly so
here we have seven you try and unpin but
now comes the bishop characters only 5d
characters and again d6 is a huge
problem bishop d8 and now rook captures
an e5 just loses this pawn white white
will just be much better queen is coming
to the nasty white squares and black
black will not be able to hold this so
stockfish saw that well capturing and h6
doesn't really do anything stalkers
played see for now ideas like Knight d7
to c5 a common mind as now the c5 square
is available for this night and maybe
then the knight can also come to c3 but
offices nope Knight to g5 and there's
really no reply to 96
we have g6 now you don't want to keep
any pressure going here on the h7 square
so g6 by stockfish and now Knight to e6
and here again you have a problem how do
you save the rook you don't because if
you play rook to f7 to defend the bishop
on c7 just rook captures on f4 the Queen
is under attack you have to play Queenie
7 and then rook captures Queen captures
in just h5 and again the bishop pair
once the position opens up will be will
be to deadly once you can bring the
kinder game rookie three Ruby g3 black
just has no moves here so after 96 with
rook captures on e6 just getting rid of
that night I mean at this moment the e6
night is a monster night you know it's
it's better to just give up the rope so
rook captures we have D capture screen
capture stockfish now has a pawn for the
exchange but offices nope I still have
this under control
Bishop a2 now activating the bishop pair
King to g7 trying to get away from the
bishop pair but it's really not
happening the bishop pair is just too
strong we have Quinta ytube putting
pressure on the c-4 Square and now rook
to f6 you have to keep an eye on the
Queen here but it's still not enough now
stop Fischer goes in for the kill and if
you remember stockfish had a lot of
chances to capture this light square
bishop in the beginning of the game then
alpha tucked it back into f1 and now
this Bishop is going in for the kill
Bishop ers on c4 attacking the Queen
Knight captures on c4 and now Queen
captures on c4 so capturing the Queen
makes no sense as rook captures your
rook is pin do to the bishop this is
just dead lost so stalkerish plate Queen
captures on c4 we have rook captures and
c4 Knight captures on c4 and now what do
you play here you don't even have to
pause the video of course not capturing
the rook but rook is seven just picking
up the bishop or forcing a a a an
unfavorable trade so King to f8 is
played but now Bishop captures on f6 now
still a being of the exchange that the
ship is under attack with rush up to DA
and now the very nice rook to e4
offering a trade Bishop for a knight
Knight d2 but now rook captures on f4 so
here we have a trade you can't avoid the
trade I mean you could but it doesn't
really do any good you have to capture
it Bishop captures the rook captures
would check King to e7
and now rook back to f4 and here stalker
still has a pawn for the exchange but
even in human chess it's a very hard
that a grandmaster will hold this
against another grandmaster but in alpha
zeros case please playing this position
would black against alpha zero is just
just an insult but you know
the engines have to play it out until
the losing side is you know losing I
think by its own evaluation by ten
points so at this point it's still not
ten points so tonight's the be three and
now starfish alpha just brings the King
into the game King f1 with night the c5
and now h5 trying to create more
weaknesses and the King side for the
rook to gobble up the pawns with a 5 by
starfish and now King to e2 just
bringing the King into the game nights
the e6 attacking the rook rook the c4
now we have Knight back the c5 not
allowing an infiltration we are looped
the c7 check and now King to e3 alpha
for the ring he improves the activity of
the King King to e6 and now rook to g4
we have team to f7 and here rook back to
d4 there are two weaknesses now King to
e6 and here alpha doesn't just capture
to create some sort of a lonely pawn on
the King side but rather h6 this is just
a good good stuff once again alpha true
- true - alpha grabbing more space we
have king te 7 keeping an eye on the d6
pawn there's no way around this and now
f4 we have night to e6 now attacking the
rook rook to d2 and Knight back to c5
and now looked a - defending the a4 pawn
with Knight to d7 and now rook the b2
and here we have king - king to f6 now
alpha just play the rope to b5 and it
was in this position that stuff is
resigned the game as it's well it's not
yet a tube swung but it will be in a few
moves black is really move us here
you could try King e6 but then g4 comes
if you repeat king of six g5 check King
e6 and now after King the before you
have normal wolves you can't move the
knight as you lose the pawn you can't
really move the anything here if you
move the King you allow King here so
you're gonna lose this point you could
try can give 7 King divine King g7 yes
you still defend the pawn but then white
gets King to c6 and and well again what
do you play you can play King g6 and
then alpha could play f5 check or if you
capture with the King you lose the night
so cap
now g6 and now captures and now h7 this
is just excellent stuff and after a 95
check hoping for night of 7-2 guard here
how could you just capture with check
and the next move you're gonna bring a
queen into the game and that is it so of
course a stockfish as of this moment has
a ruby 5 decided that it was more than a
losing more than by a 10-point
evaluation and the game ended here so
there we have it we haven't had an Evans
gambit game you know long in a long time
I hope this to rectify this as soon as
possible
but they would have it what better you
know entity to play the Evans gambit
then alpha 0 so really I hope you
enjoyed this I really enjoyed it really
Thank You Dario for recommending such a
lovely game and yeah it's just great
great great stuff great chess so you
know remember when someone tells you
Evans gambit is a bad is the bad opening
you just play the Evans gambit you know
give up some points keep your Bishop
pair and you know win brilliant games
like this so once again that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it as usual you
can check to my previous videos see
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content continuing the
couple Wonka saga although I will
continue the couple Wonka saga when I
return to my home town not here I prefer
doing it at my setup at home checking up
on your suggestions which are insanely
good such as this one and of course
keeping up with everything what what
goes on in the chest world thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day